quest to learn is this new public school
that we opened in New York City in the
fall it'll eventually be a 6th grade
through 12th grade public school right
now we just have 6th graders and it's a
school that has been designed from the
ground up to try to pay attention to the
notion that we have a whole generation
of digital kids and we're specifically
that because my interest is in game
design and there's been increasing kind
of research around the fact that kids
playing games today are learning to see
the world in some pretty interesting
ways that we wanted to not only tap into
digital generation and designing to
school but also begin to think about
well how could the structures of games
be used to design a school in a way that
was really engaging for kids really got
at content expertise but also began to
work on some of these 21st century
skills that people thought are talking
about collaboration working in teams
complex problem solving systems thinking
being able to kind of design and find
resources and so the schools really been
designed as a school that uses games as
a pedagogical kind of structure so it's
not a school where kids are playing
video games all day which is a common
misperception but it's a school that
uses game like learning
there's many different kinds of tools
that we use so sometimes we do board
game design with kids sometimes we have
been doing mobile game design with kids
so kids designing games with cell phones
and so they may be using Bluetooth
technology they may be using something
called QR code or semi code technology
which are visual barcodes the cameras
take pictures of and they design games
in the environment that use these
barcodes
if you tell the kid what you need to
learn about predator prey and we're
going to like read about it in a
textbook we're going to watch it on a
film you know they may get interested in
it they probably feel like they're doing
school but if you tell them listen work
on your challenge is to design a game
about a predator and prey those kids
will spend hours and hours researching
like what's an interesting predator and
prey that they want to work with what
are the specific relationships that they
know they need to develop they start
drawing drawing the elements of the game
so the characters so that maybe they
choose a you know a rabbit in a wolf
they begin to really understand the
landscape and they go deep deep deep
into that content and really become
experts at it because to design a game
you have to really know what you're
talking about in order to create a
system that models that idea so kids go
deep into content when they design games
about something the second thing is that
because games require a player from the
outset the designer has to think about
their user and this is actually very
different than a lot of other different
design areas of design with a game you
bring a player in right away even when
you just have a paper prototype of it
and that player starts playing with your
game and they tell you what they think
and for kids this is a profound moment
where they suddenly begin to really
understand notions of point of view they
really begin to understand ideas and
empathy so how do I step outside of
myself and what i want and begin to
listen to what that player is telling me
about their experience in this game and
that for me also was a very eye-opening
situation to begin to think about kinds
of civics curriculum ways for teachers
to begin to use game design as a way to
get kids to think more broadly about
opinions outside of their own ways of
collaborating and so those are two
really big things that I find game
design gives kids when they have the
opportunity to do it
one of the arguments we make around game
design and also just the way that play
happens and games is that you have to
learn how to how to problem-solve and
iterate and things are constantly
changing and so you try something out it
doesn't quite work you try something new
you look for a certain kind of resource
it's there and that is gone so we have
to find another kind of resource and so
that Billy ability to resource
intelligently the ability to find stuff
when you need it knowing who to go to
the ability to understand that
everything is in process that nothing is
really ever a final solution that
certain kind of tools are effective at
one moment it may be less effective at
another moment technology is changing
all the time we have to constantly learn
how to do new stuff every day if we
don't equip kids with an ability to
understand that and know how to do it
they're not just going to like learn it
on their own schools actually have a
pretty important role in helping kids do
that
I had some great math teachers in high
school and I was a kid that was
interested in conceptual things and so I
loved things like geometry and I love
things like trigonometry and calculus
and doing proofs was something I got
incredible pleasure doing and I think it
was because it was about solving
problems and it was about thinking
through how you could sequence a set of
ideas in such a way that you actually
arrived at a pretty interesting
conclusion I have a friend great game
designer named Frank lance and he talks
about game design as math sex because in
essence when you're designing a game
you're dealing with all kinds of issues
of mathematics and programming you're
trying to discover what combinations of
resources when combined together will
lead to certain kinds of results and
that when you work in computer games
that eventually comes down to doing math
developing algorithms trying to figure
out procedurally what might happen in a
game dealing with lots of if-then
statements so that work in calculus was
actually a pretty great practice space
for the kind of thing you do when you
design games which is again trying to
figure out well if my player does this
and then they do this what kind of event
does that give rise to and then what new
opportunities might be there to continue
to kind of build on that argument
you